Fore.
Okay. Uh her name is Tantri. She's a
teacher. She's asking if there's a
contradiction in Quran. In surah al
bakar ayat number 256 Allah says however
in surah al chapter 6 verse number 30
to37 there is a story where sulaman
forced balis and the country nation to
embrace Islam. So is there a
contradiction?
>> Sister says in surah bakar chapter 2
verse number 256 Allah say like there's
no compulsion. In surah anam she's
saying sulamanisam forced bilis to
accept Islam your understanding of the
Quranic vers is long he presents gives
her an offer to accept doesn't force her
you cannot force anyone to accept the
dean he offers her to accept the I asked
the earlier girl would you like to
accept Islam is anyone forcing you she
said no so similarly in Islam you cannot
force anyone to accept Islam
Smallam offered her that this is the
guidance from almighty god. Do you
accept it? He never used the sword or
the or the thing to to force her.
Nowhere does the Quran say that he
offered her to accept the true religion.
That's what the Quran says. Hope that
answers the question.